[Music]
uh
[Music]
did this
[Music]
such a crazy world there's two cases in
one spot just a couple of cases hanging
out oh man yesterday we mounted the
camera we found a good mounting solution
up over there today we're actually doing
the reel mounting up here and we could
use the scissor lift but why use a
scissor lift when you can use a ladder
it's a lot safer
i used to paint houses
so basically once you get the ladder in
the position where you want it just
perfect
i coated the bottom of my shoes with a
fresh coat of butter this morning
[Applause]
so several months back i showed you guys
some ancient roman coins that i bought
online my side hobby of mine recently
has been getting into ancient
numismatics so basically collecting and
studying and researching ancient coins
so it is possible to buy cleaned coins
that have been already researched and
everything but part of the fun of it for
me is to buy these unclean coins that
have literally just been dug out of the
ground by metal detector and then you
buy them usually on ebay or on other
sites that are dedicated to ancient coin
collecting part of the fun is the
mystery you never know what's going to
be under that layer of dirt do you guys
express some interest in seeing what i
found over half of them have barely any
detail and they've been corroded to a
point where you can't really tell what
they are or they're just hunks of rusted
metal that's going to happen however
many of them i've been able to actually
clean to a pretty good degree of
cleanliness and actually been able to
identify and there's been some pretty
interesting results i found quite a
diversity in where these were actually
minted within the roman empire so for
example here we have a coin that was
minted with the image of emperor valens
this coin was minted in the province of
aqualia now that's in the northeastern
part of what was then the main roman
part of italy however this coin found in
the same lot was minted in antioch which
is a city in turkey this coin this is a
gratian it was actually minted in the
city of rome the romans had hundreds of
mints spanning across their empire so
again diversity in mints it's pretty
crazy to see how these coins changed
hands and made it to the opposite end of
the empire
it's pretty sturdy
okay i'm gonna try to get this attached
that's pretty tight look at the size of
this lens
yeah this is the 11 to 24 canon uh lens
for a full frame sensor like the 5d mark
ii
uh mark iii most cameras like the 80d
has an aps-c sensor which is smaller
than full-frame full-frame sensors are
bigger and they require the right lenses
for it and this is one of those lenses
for that camera so basically at 11
millimeters it'll look like a gopro lens
super super super wide
i oh it
i'm so glad i had my hand on it it
literally just broke on me i was like
see those those two ends there
yep that's the inside of that metal bolt
it's not supposed to be like that
i can't man that was actually going to
work way better too until i broke it it
literally just failed at the stress
concentration right here because you see
how it gets really small all right so
i'll just need something to crank this
tight because that was our issue is that
i can't using just my fingers i can't
tighten this tight enough
everyone has their own methods of
cleaning what i choose to do is use a
very fine sewing needle scraping down
the dirt layer by layer careful not to
hit that patina only get the dirt and
corrosion off i picked a random coin
this is a totally unclean coin i'll
spend about an hour cleaning it and then
i'll show you guys what i have as you
can see right now you can't see anything
it's just a basically it looks like a
little fleck of dirt but under there
could be some detail maybe i could even
see what emperor it is maybe i could
even see where it was minted it's about
50 50 chances so i spent about an hour
cleaning up this coin here i was able to
actually get most of the dirt off with
this coin i wasn't able to make out the
mint mark nor was i able to make out the
emperor's full name yet most likely
either constantine constantine ii
constantius or constans so i'm not
actually sure exactly what type of coin
this is what you can make out here is on
the face side you can see the bust of
the emperor on the reverse side of the
coin you can make out a very common late
roman coin design which is a soldier who
is a roman soldier spearing a fallen
horseman so i definitely need to spend
some more time researching this coin to
find out exactly what it is if you guys
have any ideas or clues let me know
anyway hope you guys didn't get too
bored and enjoyed uh uncovering this
little tiny part of history with me
until next time how's this going now
peter we are connecting the camera
see if this works it works
so snap there's our view
oh my god whoa peter
you're tiny
[Music]